je suis jolie julie oui catastrophe elle
n'est pas là haut
françois à bonjour kazemi sommet c'est à
froid horrible catastrophique
giuly n'est pas là oui je le sais mais
mais pourquoi ces quêtes spécifiques
casimir casimir d'une inquiète il s'est
passé quelque chose de coin j'ai faim
ouf
le 20 10 dont tu meures et fait peur
mais c'est très grave
j'ai très faim je voulais lui que lui
acheter pour ce qu'il faut pour faire un
rat super gloubiboulga gyan maintien
justement ça me fait penser que
plusieurs d'entre vous m'ont demandé la
recette d'une lubie boulga ah oui moi
aussi j'ai reçu beaucoup de lettres à ce
sujet alors casimir dur profite pour
donner la recette
ah bon voilà écoutez moi bien vous
prenez un grand bol vous mettez dedans
du chocolat en poudre a une grosse part
vous ensuite à de la confiture de
fraises une grosse part aussi une grosse
part de banane écrasée de la moutarde et
de la saucisse de toulouse tiède mais
cru eu une grosse part un aussi vous
mélangez bien le tout vous écraser et
puis vous mangez c'est très bon vous
essayez si vous voulez mais je vous
préviens je n'ai jamais vu personne en
dehors de casimir et mais le
gloubiboulga un joli je t'attendais au
oui avec beaucoup d'impatience au
pourquoi parce que j'ai très faim
je voulais acheter tout ce qu'il faut
pour faire un gros cube yoga regarde j
beaucoup mieux au guidon c'est vraiment
un beau gâteau
c'est pour moi c'est pour nous c'est
vraiment une excellente idée
ah oui tu devrait rajouter quelques en
choix et des cornichons des anchois et
des cornichons la crème chantilly aubin
et toi tu remettras sur ton morceau si
tu veux mais moi j'ai pas envie de
gâcher mon gâteau quand le mange ton il
me met l'eau à la bouche et dames
maintenant si vous voulez alors on veut
on veut bon et bien suivez moi qu'est-ce
que je vais le coupé il est vraiment
trop on va se régaler casimir qui veut
mon premier morceau mois encore pour
atteindre tu emploies la méthode des
casimir hulse aveu je la connais pas
qu'est ce que sait on de cette audience
m je lui donne une part à chacun et le
dernier pour le morceau qui reste la
bombe adoptons la formule de cambon
alors attends je réfléchis c'est un peu
voilà si je prends mais seul le premier
morceau
j'aurai un petit morceau si j'attends
françois va avoir un premier morceau
petit jules y aura un deuxième morceau
encore plus petit et moi j'aurai le
troisième et dernier très gros morceau
d'accord julie je la prendrai le dernier
morceau
le dernier morceau ah bon tu écoutes
françois voilà ton morceau
merci genevois parias les assiettes
anticiper les enfants vous venez manger
le gâteau mais mais non c'était pas
prévu mais d'aller voir les enfants de
ce gâteau est pas montrée très bien mais
nous ne venait pas il est pas bon du
tout on n'allait pas manger sai
il n'y a même pas de cornichons et
d'anchois avec nous mêmes et les
dégoûter casimir à la nasa
mangeable voilà c'est très mauvais c'est
très mauvais tu vas tu as mangé pour sa
console casimir attendait son assiette
avec les as et il est bon on ne va pas
commencer les gâteaux faits dit donc
azimuts pour ce petit morceau je suis
désolé je me suis trompé dans mes
calculs il nous reste que ce petit
morceau pour nous deux oh j'aurais mieux
fait de prendre le premier morceau est
vrai comme sa quasi mais tu te
souviendras du proverbe
un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
et que casimir ne désespère pas je vais
te préparer un go gloubiboulga et puis
l'année prochaine vous frappez le gâteau
qu'on mangera c'est vrai ça casimir du
n'est pas au courant
moi on ne dit jamais rien et bien
l'année prochaine nous allons avoir
notre propre champ de blé avec des épis
et des graines au bout regarde là y'a un
stack de blé pour semer et l'année
prochaine on aura des dizaines de vies
mais voilà des dizaines de sacs de blé
pour faire des centaines de bons gâteaux
[Musique]
encore un petit effort et j'aurais moulu
tout le blé pour faire de la bonne
farine avec cette farine je vais faire
un délicieux gâteau
je mettrai dedans des anchois des
piments du caramel et de chocolat ça va
être délicieux et puis franchement on va
être très content parce que j'ai suivi
ses bons conseils
ça va quasiment très bien françois tu
vas être très content dis donc qu'est ce
que tu fais là
eh bien je suis vite et conseils mais
quels conseils à un tiens vaut mieux que
deux tu l'auras et du faisceau avec le
blick que l'on devait se met dans notre
show points bien sûr tu vas être content
mon dauphin casimir l'année prochaine
nous n'aurons pas de récolte
non mais comme dit le proverbe un tiens
voilà un bon gâteau vaut mieux que
tournera sur l'année prochaine
[Musique]